(clicks)
(laughs)
- [Tom] What about you young
lady you have a question?
- Yeah, so Anders, you're known
for spitting some mad fire,
- Uh-Oh.
- Oh here we go.
- And would you honor us with
a little bit of freestyle?
(cheers and applause)
- I'll do like the
shortest thing ever.
Slow me down, slow me down.
(beat boxes)
♪ Oh shit hit the lights
it's about to get tight
♪ I'm rapping with my boys
to the left and the right
♪ Blakes got the hair on
flair everybody get buck naked
♪ Except keep on your underwear
♪ Cause I don't want
to see the dicks
♪ They might have a
little zits on them
♪ Catch a phrase
and I flip on them
♪ Sneak phrase, peak ways
♪ I'm ins we ♪
- Something about a
deep haze, like weed,
so that was that.
- Sneak phrase.
- Yeah.
- Yeah!
- that was it.
- That was it.
- Come on make some noise.
(cheers and applause)
Make some noise.
- [Anders] What, what, what,
it's getting hot in here.
And that'll be on
Youtube for sure.
- Pass the mic to Blake.
- That shit was ill.
- And I pass the mic to Adam.
- I don't want the mic.
Adam doesn't want the mic,
he passes the mic to Kyle.
- Nah, it's okay, I
don't want the mic,
it's going right back to Ders.
- Kyle's not drunk
enough to take the mic
but he'll take the mic.
- Drunk yeah, sure.
- He looks down at his feet
and just gets real
with the deal.
- What's cool is you got
good at freestyle rapping
but you're the only person
that I know that's good
at freestyle rapping.
'Cause that was everyone
from like my high school.
You'd be in somebody's basement
and kids would get drunk
and then people would be
like, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo,
(beat boxes)
♪ This is a keg, I got two legs
♪ You're names Fred ♪
- We be drinking.
All damn day, what do you say.
- Hey.
(laughs)
- Frito Lay.
(cheers)
- Big chips.
- Holdin' on a
tomato, don't hate-o
(audience laughs)
- [Adam] That was good,
that was good actually.
That was.
- That was cool.
- That was really good.
- Hidden talent.
- Tomato.
- Who's got a back pack
full of hidden talent?
- Hip hop.
- Sneak phrase.
(audience laughs)
- Sneak phrase all days.
- [Tom] Hey Blake
what's in the back pack?
- A Wolverine mask.
- Oh.
- Shout out to Wolverine.
(audience laughs)
I wish Hugh Jackman was
just here right now.
- Hey you guys aren't
funny, your not funny guys.
- He just stands up.
(audience laughs)
- Ey mate, keep my
name out yer mouth.
- He just goes bull shit
and leaves.
This panel is bullshit.
- You had me until you started
talking about Wolverine
and now I'm outta here.
- Now I'm outta here!
I was a huge fan,
very loose butt hole,
this panel's very
loose butt hole.
(audience laughs)
That's my best
Australian accent.
- It's good.
It's good.
- Not even close.
(audience laughs)
- [Anders] It's not.
We have another question
from the audience.
- [Blake] It's funny though.
I thought it was,
- [Anders] Hi.
- Hello.
(stumbles over each other)
- [Anders] I'm sorry you go
- [Questioner] Wait me or you?
- [Adam] No you, you.
No, it's fine, you just.
- Should I go now?
- [Panel] Stay.
- It's me.
- [Adam] Stay you go.
- Are you sure.
- Oh my god.
- [Kyle] Yeah go.
- Okay, alright sorry.
- Oh my god, you're cute.
- Okay, ask your question.
- Oh my god he's cute.
- Okay.
(audience ahs)
- Well, uh.
First off, I was really.
- What the hell happened?
- What the hell
happened back there?
That was just a wave
of laughter so far away
from anything that happened.
- It's like half the
audience saw something
that none of us saw.
- Yeah.
- Shit.
What's your question sir?
- So first off I want to say
that I was really bummed out
when I found out
Jet Set passed away.
- [Adam] Oh.
- He was one of my
favorite characters.
- Way to bring the mood down.
- I'm sorry.
(audience laughs)
I'm sorry.
- RIP Jet Set.
- Okay but my
actual question is,
- He was like an extra to Adam.
- [Announcer] Thanks for
bringing the mood down asshole.
- It's okay.
- Is it at least a tight?
- Yeah.
- Alright.
- Rest in peace Jet Set.
- We probably wanna take this
and say something serious.
Say something serious
about this right,
this must have been a,
- Yeah it was fucked up.
- Very sad.
- It was.
- Finished our like
last day of shooting
- Second to last.
- Second to last and then
didn't come up for the last day.
- And Jet Set was always on
set, like on time with a smile
and then it was like
where's Jet Set,
something's up?
- You knew something was up.
- It was a bummer.
- He was the coolest,
we hired him as just like
in an extra casting book
and we were going
through and we were like,
holy shit.
(audience laughs)
We have to hire this guy.
- Yeah.
- His name is Jet Set.
- Coolest stinking man ever.
- He looked like he was
from the future past.
Yeah.
- [Anders] Yeah.
- You're like what
generation is this guy from?
- Homie had a look.
- yeah, yeah.
- With a hard K.
- Very particular look
and his name legitimately
was Jet Set Hudson.
- Yeah.
- So.
- We had to meet him.
- Very castable.
- Yeah.
- But what was your
actual question before you
blew the whole
fucking mood in here?
- Yeah, thanks a lot.
(burps)
- Adam, Adam, Adam come back.
- [Questioner] My
actual question was
I know you guys are
still writing this season
but how percentage could be
reoccurring characters like,
- Recurring.
Reoccurring, recurring.
- I do that to man.
- Okay so, I'm his cop.
- He catches me.
- What is it, is it
recurring or reoccurring?
- What's your next
next question?
- Okay, percentage of new
characters, old characters,
what kind of thing should we
expect from the new season?
- Percentage?
- Uh, front, outer, inner, last.
We gotta foil this math.
- Either the carry the
thing, the remainder.
- Uh.
17%.
- 17%.
- [Anders] Okay thank you
next, next questioner.
- I have no idea
what he just asked.
- [Tom] Get outta here.
- A over b times.
- [Tom] Hi.
- Hi.
- [Tom] What's your name?
- Woo, my names Megan.
- [Tom] Woo Megan.
- [Anders] Hi.
- Hi you're doing great.
- Any of you guys have
a question for Megan?
- Yeah how are you doing?
- Pretty good.
- [Blake] Great.
- Yeah, oh wait, I think I,
I'm sorry, I just cha cha cha.
- Okay Megan, we're
gonna ask you questions.
- You're doing great so far.
- Adam do you have a
question for Megan?
- Uh so what's up?
- Nothing.
(audience laughs)
you know hanging
out at ComicCon.
- That's my pick up
line, is I squint my eyes
and say what's up.
(audience laughs)
It's worked on never, so.
- Okay Megan, now
you can ask one.
- Okay, well I actually
got two parts to this
just to let you guys know.
- Let's go with the second part.
- Okay, well, I'll make it
the more important part.
- [Panel] Okay.
- So I hung out in Denver
for a couple hours,
if you guys wanna hang out
after whatever you're doing,
you know,
- In Denver we'll
be in San Diego?
- Yeah, no not Denver,
I brought Denver here.
- Oh.
- the glass dinosaur?
- [Questioner] Yeah.
- Oh shit then hell yeah.
- I'm very confused.
- Yeah, the glass
dinosaur we're kicking it
with the glass dinosaur.
- I'm wearing a white
shirt and orange pants.
- [Anders] We got
you we got you.
- You're the one
that looks like you.
- Hair face, like the glasses.
- We got you.
- [Adam] Okay cool.
- [Anders] You know
what we look like.
- Yeah, yeah, I
saw Kyle earlier,
I waved at you in line.
- Alright,
- alright very cool.
- Hey.
- Cool.
- I think you were the one
with the orange pants right?
- Yeah.
- And the orange pants,
- and the white shirt, yeah.
- Mental picture taken.
- I think we were just
invited to an orgy.
- Yeah, this.
- I don't know
- Yeah okay,
- Taking photos
of you right now.
- Thank you Megan, very.
(man in the audience shouts)
- [Panel] Oh!
- No, somebody get
him, escort him out.
- Look at this dude.
You did it.
(man shouts)
- It's getting all Jerry
Springer all of a sudden.
(audience laughs)
- Dad?
(man shouts)
- Yeah what's up dude.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, get him.
- What are you from Concord bro?
- Get him a mic device.
- Yeah I'm from DBC.
- DBC, this dude.
- DBC!
- Diablo Valley College.
- Community college.
- Yeah that's right I know it.
All right, all right.
- Hell yeah, it all makes sense.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- He fucking did it.
- Stay hydrated.
(audience laughs)
- [Anders] Stay high-drated.
- Representing the 95.
- How in the hell was that?
(audience laughs)
- Making us proud man.
- Hey that's just Concord.
- That's just Concord for you.
- That's Concord baby.
- He's just wandering around.
- Hell yeah.
- Yeah.
- Look at him, check at
him he's patrolling the
- Cool.
- Who is this guy?
- I like that.
- That was actually
the best question.
- Yeah,
- yeah.
- It was very a very
specific question.
- Check it out, every body
look at him for a second.
Just look at him.
- Look at this dude.
- Some girl's gonna suck his
dick later because of that.
- Okay what's uh, who's
next with a question here?
- [Question] Hey what's up guys.
- Hey.
- [Panel] What's up.
- Um, I know that Ders, you
were on The Mindy Project
and I wanted to know
what that was like,
and for all of you, how was it
being on Arrested Development
'cause like it was a great
thing to come back, so.
(cheers and applause)
- Chi-O.
- I'll be short and
sweet, it was a lot of fun
being on Mindy Project but it
was lonely without my boys.
- Ah.
- My boys.
- Are we the boys?
- Yeah, you guys are the boys.
- All right.
- You know, you
guys are the boys.
And uh.
That's a look.
That actually looks unreal.
- Cyclops put your
shades back on.
(audience laughs)
Oh I'm sorry, did Adam
just get cast in X-men,
I think so.
- Boo-Yah.
(audience laughs)
- New Cyclops.
- Sorry, fire eyes,
new character.
- I like it, fire eyes.
- He's gonna be
the coolest uncle.
- Arrested Development
was totally kick ass
and awesome to
answer your question.
- Yeah.
- Now back to my eye thing.
- Meh.
And a mouth, and a
mouth, and a mouth.
Well you gotta put one in.
(audience laughs)
And the ear, and the ears.
(cheers and applause)
And I get to work with
this guy every day
are you kidding me?
- Tight butt hole.
- Hashtag blessed.
We did something right.
- What was our new
words, sneak phase?
Sneak phase.
- [Panel] Sneak phrase.
- Sneak phrase.
- Sneak phase is when you're
trying a new face though.
- Sneak face.
Sneaky face.
- Arrested was dope I
feel like we were a part
of something that
was cool finally.
- Yeah, it was very cool.
(audience laughs)
- That was cool.
- Shots fired itself.
- It was really really
really fun and Mitch Hurwitz
the creator of
Arrested Development,
is just the coolest,
smartest guy
and made us feel so stupid.
- Yeah, he's too funny,
where you're like uh.
- He's so quick.
- Yeah, funniest
guy I've ever met.
- Yeah.
- Hands down.
Besides my grandpa.
(Workaholics theme plays)